hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play Red Dead
Redemption - I made a pit stop I know I
said I'd be all the way back by now but
eg is right here so I'm not gonna pass
up the opportunity to go say hi to eg is
that a horse alright I'm not gonna
question that too much but hey are you a
G yeah you look it by your picture I
think I distinctly remember the look at
you you swine fancy air hey Emmett
how you doing what are you doing howdy
you Granger that's my name and Malik a
patient too if you hadn't noticed always
used to be a quick-draw guy new gym boy
cattle we used to be correct then
there's a long who might you be
don't matter I need you to tell me about
Jim boy just a quote for a book a book
about Jim boy well [ __ ] I can't talk to
you now look at me a knee deep in hog
crap no mommy we can talk while you work
I ain't talking and shoveling besides
young man like you would get it done in
half the time oh no no you interested in
the old days
do you shovel this [ __ ] I tell you some
stories you keep your hands clean I
don't give you squat damn it squats is
another word for poop and I know that
doors yes
alright whatever you say okay
I killed men women and children to
animals I even killed rocks and I killed
them good
I shot folks stabbed folks skinned folks
scalps great stories man oh yeah you
turned my stomach with these stories
yeah yeah
legs and that's not a story about Jimbo
probably okay keep talking man y'all
clean enough to eat that barrel to the
[ __ ] pile and I suppose you is no hands
stinks
yeah I wonder why me because [ __ ] clean
up your mask
tell me about Calloway I said I tell you
stories
I didn't say there'd be a body don't
trifle with me old man
you knew just give me something Annie
you're making a book you should make it
about me they're just words
Oh give me something to say and I'll
leave you alone you owe me there hey you
be careful killer like me it don't take
must end up on the end of my knife once
I know what I don't think you were
anything at all just a crazy old man
anything
well you'd already be hog feed I had me
to deal with the Federals got this far
this is your last chance mr. Granger
give me a quote for the box
you know man a piece told you I'll meet
you to drop you girlie only wait with my
time I got too much to lose too much to
lose
well seeing as I cleaned up this pigsty
figure I'm in my raps to reckon you
don't wanna do that you walk away right
now I'm going to blow up your [ __ ] oh
yeah that's a better idea than the one I
had I was gonna go for like the Big Bend
or something but this is so much better
oh there's gonna be so much [ __ ]
everywhere well this is the best thing
I've ever seen
okay whatever you say okay sure yeah
yeah yeah all right let's see what you
got here hope oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I wasn't
ready for that
I wasn't ready holy [ __ ] I didn't know
you're gonna throw a knife I thought you
were gonna shoot or something I don't
know I don't know what I was thinking
let's see if I can do this without
killing you but I'm probably not gonna
know you don't whoa what's up whoa whoa
whoa you're done okay apparently you're
not done all right well man these guys
these guys really don't want to be alive
that's that's a that's a damn sure thing
about all this like these guys whoo whoo
all right well there you go
I think this is every kind of wrong like
everything about this is just completely
100% wrong okay well anyway pitstop just
mosey and be on my way gosh
Lupul Oh Marsh won't but we got places
to be things do people to see I got
damnit
no wonder I can't keep a hat on in the
game wait where's my hat what god damn
it
I got a dress myself up a little better
I'm still in the basic outfit that I've
had since the beginning of the game oh
well I don't know where to do that is
there a place there like a clothing
place oh wait the tannery that's right
that's why I was getting all this
leather so I go to the tannery okay I'm
gonna go back to the to the base and I'm
gonna go to the tannery and that's where
I need to be it was a gun
wait what is that gun about the special
gun what's this all about
Oh ooh that's a nice gun let's say you
look at it see what conditions it's in
of course got covered and [ __ ] but I
think it's okay all right yeah
I'm okay with that hot damn I got a
better pistol I think it even does but
more like a lot more base damage which
is probably gonna be good in the long
run because my pistol has not been
capable of killing nobody no way no how
so long as I get some more damage and I
think it'll be perfectly usable
oh hello wild horse how are you doing
you take care now I ain't gonna bother
with you don't more don't worry about
nothing like this bunny on the other
hand is not gonna have a good day did I
get it I have no idea if I got enough
goddamn it well I don't think that's
working I'm trying real hard to keep
this out on my head but it just don't
work I wish it did ah it's fallen it's
guys I got this head fool
wait hello incoming
these guys are fast these guys are fast
but they're gonna get tuckered soon nope
that's nothing oh sorry okay hang on I
got it that's a bad pelt now I'm gonna
get you come on hat stay on my head stay
on the head exam ahead go horse go oh my
horse is out of energy no don't get it
it's right there there we go that's a
good what what what damn it god damn it
you're making me look bad in front of
the everybody huh I'm gonna let this go
I ain't gonna let this go
you're doing good yeah you're doing good
oh you're tired aren't you I know you're
tired but it's okay
we gotta get this one we gotta get it
there's a different one all right well
that'll do no not god damn it all right
this'll have to do
gotcha okay you weren't what I was what
now why is this suddenly not working no
more I'm gonna get you even if I have to
swim after you what are you doing over
there you uh he's going for a swim
we're come out come on out come on I
don't know how I'm gonna work this but
Oh God eyebrows Oh Oh God Oh
this don't feel right here we go Oh God
Oh like wrestling a gator oh well I
don't know how I'm gonna be able to get
this oh okay okay okay let's just try to
try to push you to shore I'm real sorry
about this
oh god this feels bad no this goes wrong
can I pick you up now oh god I almost
had a chance come on
oh god get over there just pick you up
okay god I didn't mean for any of that
to happen
Oh God okay all right well then I'm
gonna put my hat back on a big ol howdy
to all you and let's get this thing
skinned and ready to go get over a horse
it's not even a good skin it wasn't able
worth it goddamn oh boy
all right I'll just I'll see you guys
when I get back to camp see you there
rampe oh that's not around
Oh oh no oh no it's party in the USA oh
god damn it oh why did I have to try to
take my horse for a ramp
oh come on let's go let's go let's go
come on come on turn oh if I kick
can I have my kicking helping Hill hey
yeah yeah yeehaw
what's this look like from this view
yeah we all real well no yeah no okay
well let me try hopping off and calling
you over I can't go here come here horsy
come here horsey oh no oh no oh no all
right
dive Bob on the horsey here we go I'm
gonna push you out of here go push it
out here here we go we're gonna push you
gonna push you here we go push it come
here come here
go ahead oh god I've got my horse stuck
okay well I guess I'm going on foot then
huh I'll see you when I see a horse damn
me you know what actually I wonder do I
have any dynamite left yeah I do okay
let me just do one of these moves
Oh squat on that it hurt but at least I
think that'll reset my horse cuz
otherwise the horse would just still be
there if I know I think about that last
door as I left in the desert it was it
didn't teleport back the base until like
way way later so I'm just gonna deal
with that that's gonna be the way and
everything will be hunky-dory until
you know things move on so oh ye ha
where are you horsey you're out here
horse horse there you are roomful good
old swampy the Pompey alright let's get
back into it I know I keep saying like
he'll come back whatever I get back to
base but it's never an uneventful
journey back to the base no matter what
I do
oh one more no not dynamite do not hunt
that with dynamite oh come on come on
come on Dale come on no come on come on
come on it's gonna be challenged like
it's like in Star Wars when they're
going through the woods ah no stop no
here we go you and get nailed it
listen I don't know who just called my
name well I am more than a little busy
right now
that's a doozy alright boo but its
pristine oh [ __ ] what the hell well hell
yeah god damn it I was right here why
did I have to try to wrap my horse dude
shut up I am not in the mood
I am so unbelievably not in the mood I
lost so many pellets okay guys I don't
know what to do about this I've now got
one help and I don't know where the
tannery is I don't know what's happening
over here I don't understand I just want
to live is this something I can use
materials oh god those are oh God
Oh God all of those are tough to get I
gotta go get beaver well god did legend
to the east what does that even mean
Oh greatly expands carrying capacity for
all items type okay all right god damn
it okay okay okay I guess we know we got
it full high yeah apparently I do
oh hell oh boy let me give you some good
Pat's there okay I why can I not Pat you
hello looking for you they went out to
the moonshine stash said you knew where
that was they was planning a visit to
the Braithwaite place but John needs to
do something for Dutch now so hosea
wants you to join him instead uh seems
to be a lot going on yeah it seems to be
a lot but looks can be deceiving
in reality I'm actually doing a whole
lot of nothing so um can I give this dog
a pat please what do you do I don't pup
we don't that I will never be able to
pet you will I please yes oh I feel
better now can't feel better I don't
have enough but at least I feel a little
better about things I wonder since I can
stack a bunch of pelts I'm a horse I
wonder if I can actually stack a bunch
of carcasses on my horse that might make
sense yeah then again maybe it won't all
right who needed to talk to me oh wait
I'm already on a mission what am i doing
John needed me somewhere oh that's right
Hosea all right I'm gonna go out looking
for that I lost all my [ __ ] but that's
okay oh my god what is your deal I don't
want to know about it just just back off
I got to go find John I'm already on a
mission shut up
yeah yeah so I also got to find a beaver
pelt I guess I can find beavers by the
river
this isn't River isn't Lake all right so
I got to find a river I just want to get
where I need to be in peace I just want
to go somewhere
look there's a there's like a oh my
controller [ __ ] off what the hell is
happening no not that
go god [ __ ] damn it ah [ __ ] Dick's my
ass okay all right I'm gonna do some
crafting of my own I've got an iPhone
cord here no no thread through this hole
or I'm not gonna thread it through
because I don't know what I'm trying to
thread it through the fat end god
[ __ ] Dana came keep my goddamn hand
on sheriff in town
his name is markiplier okay you sons of
[ __ ]
let's get back to bidness now I don't
want any of this ridiculousness that's
been happening thus far I want to get to
where I'm gonna go I don't wanna get
there fast and I don't want any nonsense
getting in the way you understand me
swoop oh you can't jump over a goddamn
rock oh my god okay listen I can't even
pet you
I can't even brush you I can't even feed
you there we go just eat some goddamn
goats shut up you'll be fine there you
go just a little brush you like the
brush you like brush it did did did good
there you go all healed up rocks
it's alright any more ridiculousness
oh hey I guess I'm done I needed to go
to fear selling it back to where it came
from
why I've got a market for it they made
it they must have someone to sell it to
stop look kind of lonely out yeah I
think we'll cut ourselves a deal yeah
yeah you and Dutch was just doing your
duty when you requisitioned it now I'm
doing mine
alright I should get going now okay wait
John why don't you later got you asked
him to look into something to do with
the Braithwaite horses the thing ok ok
ok let's head out to the braithwaite's
place you know the way ya think I know
so what exactly are we done this is the
moonshine we took after blowing up the
braithwaite's - right
I think the good citizens taken the
trouble to return their stolen goods
deserve some roll order don't you and
it's time we made
formal introduction but doctor told us
make sense America these are two big old
plantation houses I keep hearing is they
hate each other so much they can't see
past it I know I've seen Forrest Gump up
in there well I'm sure there's money in
this for us somewhere if we can get in
the middle of it okay makes sense hello
there may I have a word with the man the
man of the house is a lady mrs.
Katherine Braithwaite may I speak with
her I want to discuss a business
opportunity I mean no harm
you may happily shoot me if I do okay
okay
okay well yeah just hop on don't worry
about it I can definitely take up
another passenger yeah okay you'll be
watching me okay please
yes sir mr. Hosea man who is not my boss
you're not even close to my boss what's
with the big boiling pots that's a
little uh very cultish was I supposed to
circle around probably whatever here
what you won't found something out in
the hills stuck up maybe you was in the
market for it
Oh what some liquor ain't in the market
for what's over there my way we see it
it's ours well with us possessing it and
I checked all over for the life of me I
couldn't see your name on it
I ain't here to rob you no it seems
that's easy enough wine I do a deal what
do you sell that stuff a dollar a bottle
give us 50 cents it's already ours
look I know there's a reward for finding
in the property alternative is we'll go
sell it someplace else the alternative
is you get shot now who wants to get
shot over a bottle or two of liquor pay
the man yeah I think they fancy each
other I think they're good we didn't
take it at least not without orders
exactly who gave you your orders old
sheriff gray you know what I don't want
it in fact sir now you can do me a favor
there's an extra ten bucks if you do
drop the stuff in the roads head over to
the tavern run by mr. gray and give the
stuff out for free ma'am
hush now I believe they call that a
promotional expense as you wish madam
you boys come back sometime and tell me
how you made out hmm I like her ID oh
man they're sweet on each other oh oh
wow they oh wow they are yeah anyway I
like her character I like her character
not bad considering how hot they were
especially after that [ __ ] bath and
Valentine Oh apparently Cornwall's been
pumping a lot of cash into the
Pinkertons wants to keep their full
effort on going after dings thanks like
us yeah you guys are taking a harder
turn yeah that's it now we're inserting
ourselves in his blood whew
we'll need a plain dress you know my
feelings about your a clowns oh no I'm a
bumpkin now bring your lip board just
swim you know I look like
you can't speak idiot me grumpy me
grumpy about this but it okay I don't
know how this gonna go over okay free
moonshine that's good just a shame you
strangle are in a rage right I have two
cases of that stuff at the dam shame you
had to strangle her and he's got this
old bag of stories like a couple of
bucks I bet you would one for each of
you sir we're in the new trade of
advertising which is an American art
form about insuring people buy the
correct things I don't know one more
dollar says give us half an hour what
harm can we do in half an hour
Wow two whole dollars all right then
easy enough man security sure is lacks
around these parts but okay I guess I
ain't gonna be too too upset about it ah
careful I might strangle you and he pour
drinks fast right next 30 minutes the
drinks in this year by in this year town
are entirely free
I'm fine I got great ham bible warm
nation there go look but it look it dick
I forgot what I was doing there you go
oh holy [ __ ]
Lenny somebody get Lenny over hey gotta
woman the cops figure this out hang on
the best in the history of forever in
this game this game is the best
yeah wait I got my hat phone oh it's
doing it automatically No
resist the urge to strangle the bottle a
plus B squared equals C squared X Y
there we go oh okay and whoops that's
not what I was looking for now I want
for you there and one for you there go
for it bang boom the way
who's there oh you okay yeah wait let's
get one for you oh wait is this the
right gun let me get the better gun out
here well they're here
honk sorry buddy I'm coming I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] gunshot Jose it's kind
of a problem here uh let's see Quang oh
[ __ ] sorry Isaiah yep that's a good shot
oh [ __ ]
behind a pillar god damn it with the
pillar there we go Wow who did the oh
you got well thank you Hosea
for all your help you're just a goddamn
sweetheart Hosea oh that guy looks what
[ __ ] what did I just see okay who Fenton
Brandon
hang on I got it Adam boink
I mean boink why would they be happy
whoa we're doing that for I'm nailing
them
I'm nail em hot heavy oh you're doing oh
[ __ ]
oh I might die
[ __ ] let's ain't look good for me well I
mean we currently are so Oh
balls do you need
sorry all right sorry dad I'm good ain't
no problem here pretty good shot huh I'm
getting way better but the auto aim is
helping but let me take all the credit
for it they're not gonna have much gang
left we've killed like 30 of them yeah
whatever okay nice boom
sure is a shiny moon ting-tong ting-tong
where we got whatever just gonna dump it
in the river you think that woman set us
up yep oh okay then maybe this place is
not keep seeing those fellas some local
militia clearly not too happy to have
some new competition I'll go visit all
my bracele see what's what why we've
been making money the chest is filling
up again slowly but surely part of me
thinks we just get ourselves good and
lost but we still need a lot more money
before that can happen so for now let me
go give old mrs. Braithwaite some of
this moonshine as well let's call it a
peace offering
sure okay all right then sure yeah
that's your definition of fun we almost
died and we murdered a lot of people I
guess it's fun I had fun there every
drunk sequence is so so what do you
think about what fine folks around these
parts Oh
on the one side we have got the gray
family
Scots degenerates drunkards the local
law you couldn't make this stuff up rich
is Croesus and on the other they're
mortal enemies the braithwaite's
moonshiners hypocritical both rollin
we believe in gold and in the middle of
it all you got some inbred retelling of
Romeo and Juliet so what do you boys
thinking you try to rob them both
you sure why not because we got lawmen
in three different states after us and I
want us to get us in trouble but we need
money now we have the opportunity here
to put ourselves in the middle of
something ain't nobody gonna know we was
here because even without us these fools
are gonna kill each other anyway well
Hosea's gone back to see that
Braithwaite one of good
Hosea should definitely take the lead on
this I sent Sean over - Braithwaite man
or - now you can meet up with them or
join John and Xavier at the graves place
something to do with the braithwaite's
prize horses how the hell did we get an
in at the graced place sheriff grey
kindly put in a word with his father
it ain't that complicated we gotta
convince each family that we're on their
side
before they figure out it was us to do
not the other life will be long gone I
ain't in the revenge business dutcher
least of all for something happened a
long time ago well I guess we all got
pay for something now if you will excuse
me sir I got to write a letter okay
Arthur I'm not sure what we just got
ourselves into and whose daddy we're
talking about here but I thought you was
my daddy boss I was like a son to you
what happens if they kill me boss are
you gonna be upset about that boss can
you turn that godforsaken racket off
listen boss I just like to watch you
sleep Saul is that so wrong boss no I'm
gonna contribute now all my worldly good
I don't know what I just don't I'm just
trying to donate to the to the ledger so
that we can make some upgrades of our
provisions and whatnot 420 blaze it okay
that is your I'm your boy Pappy I'm your
boy can this get I just wasn't in my eye
before took that behind my ear okay
ledger we got to be able to upgrade
something somehow here okay look at all
that all me all day baby all me all day
okay so we need some real variety hmm
that could do that come on chubowski I
don't know what I was listening to it
beautiful hearts you boo nice hearts
okay what if we get a horse station now
chicken coop now real firepower that's
what I'm talking about now that is what
I am talking about
hey I asked that girl to give me some I
don't know what conversations not
picking up but it's very uncomfortable
this whole camp is a little weird oh
it's a song let's have some fun I know
thanks all right let's go treat yourself
cocaine chewing oh my god I forgot that
cocaine was just a thing that everybody
had back it was a good old-fashioned
cocaine why not
there we go I'm dressing up the place
because I want to be able to get all the
upgraded satchel stuff because
eventually I'm gonna need to do that I
need to give a many horse or many bodies
many carcass I want everything at least
upgrade to the next level Oh
just short damn just sure
just short okay what else we do can we
do let's do the chicken coop all right
why not one one chicken coop that was a
hundred and seventy-five dollars are you
kidding me are you yanking on my hat
here that is a bunch of buki so I gotta
do a few things I got number one I'm
gonna take a nap number one first and
foremost I'm gonna sleep until morning
number two I gotta figure out a way to
do literally anything in this game
because I want to have upgraded satchel
capacity and if I don't have upgraded
satchel capacity I'm never gonna be able
to carry anything so I gotta get carcass
eye and pelts and a whole bunch of other
stuff so I gotta do all of that and I
gotta somehow not lose it all when I get
my goddamn horse running into rocks and
[ __ ] which is gonna happen eventually so
I just got to figure out how and when
and where and why makes sense okay what
am i doing I think you mr. malvit oh
he's following me okay okay all right
then just gotta get myself some
breakfast here can you please do
anything but be near me pretty good just
getting some breakfast and then I'll be
on my way if I could just get my hat to
stay on mmm good stuff good welp I guess
I'm just not gonna have a goddamn hat
how can I eat this please can I eat it
hurry hurry go
okay there we go now we gotta get going
no no no what I'm gonna get doing - I
gotta make a decision if I'm gonna go
towards John at the graze or if I'm
gonna go elsewhere
John marcin's over there Hosea's over
there uh Bill Williamson needs my help
here sodom back to Gomorrah Oh got a
bank robbery well that sounds pretty
cool but smell right if you know what I
mean glacier
oh is that up where it was oh really
oh hell yeah is that does that mean that
I could go back to the frozen area cuz
that would be pretty cool okay but
anyway what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
for John Marston just because I like
John better screw you Bill Williamson
out her son have time to deal with your
[ __ ] at the moment and then I'm
gonna do my very damndest my very
extremely damnedest to not lose my pelts
after I get them because that is my
biggest weakness at this juncture if I
can just avoid losing my goddamn pelts
the very second oh there you are are you
doing all the way over there are you
doing all the way over there come on we
got to go we got to go I gotta go
let's go towards John let's get whatever
oh my god
that's so goddamn that's all that's so
pretty
that's so goddamn pretty oh my god oh my
god just stop that's so pretty
that's so goddamn pretty okay hey guys
um hey I gotta go get my uh get my gun
uh horse horse horse
I want that no no no no horse horse
horse get back here you freaking
frustrating piece of [ __ ] this whole
episode is just been nothing but
frustrations Lancaster repeater that's
the better one I want the rolling block
rifle the bow that's what I want okay
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to I'm
gonna basically Deadeye every single one
of these guys now watch they're gonna be
the sickest move you've ever seen and
now I just get everything that I need
you know what I don't notice why can't I
buy a pristine beaver pelt why do I
gotta go get that myself I guess it
wouldn't be much of a game if that was
the case man now I feel bad for this
because these guys were just sitting
around telling a story but they were bad
on my oh they're lemony Raiders okay so
these are the guys that can't stop
playing war
look look look guys look this
whoa where's my where's my rifle here
you wanna fight huh I'll fight you can
wait you boy you want to go ill nice
here we go
flaps oh that's not oh oh oh
vicious or brutal or viciously brutal
brutal vicious Opa Opa Opa cocaine gum
Oh feeling cocaine gum that what I saw
opioid cocaine gum Wow
that is no joke first Wow some nice coke
all right five minutes
many of the valuables in this camp that
I could use probably peaches goodies one
good stiff biscuits
alright horsie we're done here we are
done here
wait we're not done yet come here rabbit
let me ask in you I guess oh good god I
don't think you can really do that but
take your word for it take your word for
it I guess oh yeah yeah oh yeah John
that's right surely forgot I got
distracted that's the one thing that I
haven't been able to do which is just go
off into the wilderness and just mess
with people I've been so focused on
keeping the story going cuz I'm so
entranced in it that I haven't actually
taken my time around this area hello
stranger hello stranger
okay I'll hop off my horse then I guess
hello
if you name in a move move am i sitting
in the wrong place
excuse me I didn't mean any offense sir
please I don't get you mean I'm very
sorry sir
you have yourself Pandey and I apologize
for any offense I'm have inadvertently
Cowles what are you drinking mister
nothing sir nothing at all why are you
acting so strange I don't mean to I'm
sorry for any offence how could you have
offended me I have no idea but I had no
idea how I fended the last fellows and
they stole my wagon on the count of my
impedance stole your wagon four-vector
maybe not my medical practice I suppose
I was helping folk and that wasn't
popular
I was undercutting a competition well I
was too colored I was irritating in
nature well I was some know-it-all big
city slicker here to demean some good
old boys and my fine words is that
variety of my sense was a source of some
conjecture so they undercut me still
compared to the guttin castration
defenestration and crucifixion they
offered me lightly imaginative Bunch
yes no great love my medical practice to
free with my wisdom and services which
way they go down the road dad awake stay
here I'm sort of forced to please don't
go to any trouble on my account
mmm-hmm okay okay I see how this is dude
I'm gonna help you I don't take the
races
well I wish I could have heard with that
said thanks thanks man
thank you I don't know where I'm going
Mac combs in huh yeah let's go get this
wagon back I also wonder if this world
gets more populated as time goes on look
at this forest look at that for us wait
let me see my map real quick which way
am I headed oh my god that is just a
forest holy [ __ ] I think I've been
through that for us too
oh look at that it just keeps going oh
god it's a swamp oh no way dude we've
been down here we've been down here to
just shut down the moonshine thing okay
that's a bad water if I get illegally
skinned all those cows it's a weird
thought to just pop into my head but I
just like see all the cows and I like I
know I need skin so maybe I should skin
all those cows I swear I'm gonna have
one of these episodes just be the farm
and in exploring episode maybe the next
one it's literally just gonna be
chitchat and farm and exploring and not
focusing on missions right away even
though missions are gonna happen but I
want to get all these good bag upgrades
like it's something that I really want
it's a big part of the game anyway so
might as well do it right I see I marry
you come here you come get it why does
it keep happening that's been happening
more and more lately just like suddenly
it'll just break off I'm not doing
anything differently I'm not not
pressing a button it's fine I guess I
don't need it right now I'll save all
the collecting for the next episode
anyway this is the exact same place that
I went in for the moonshine so I don't
know why I will come back here why they
would have taken a wagon I mean actually
knowing the people that I stole from I
guess I know exactly whether
taking a wagon oh it's just me listen
okay listen listen listen listen
listen guys you definitely and a little
bit of
they're real okay thank you
where's the wagon guys Wow
what the hell was that for was it cuz I
killed your friends hey buddy sorry
gotcha
listen listen listen I'm just gonna walk
out in the middle and you're just gonna
try your best and you're gonna fail and
it's gonna be real sad good god I don't
know why you guys even bothered but the
wagons got to be somewhere around here
right somewhere why would you oh there
it is over there
definitely over there right I don't know
if I want to loot this one all right
well I can't anyway too deep in the muck
but there's one over here oh let me see
what this hats all about this might look
like a fine hat it is not the [ __ ] it is
it is the opposite of a fine hat this is
this is a hideous hat man why are hats
not fashionable anymore I mean I mean
hats are fashionable but I mean why why
don't everyone back in these days every
single person had a hat and now man I
miss it oh this is a great excuse me
honk honk coming through ok
oh he's fine he's fine he's fine I'm
sorry I'm sorry schwump oh I'm sorry
shuffle shuffle I'm sorry I'm real sorry
maybe in the next episode if I'm gonna
be hunting I could go hunt like the
legendary animals on the list that could
be like a fun exercise like just go high
if I I wanted this whoa what them really
you guys
I do this like this huh I'd really want
to do this watch out watch out hey hey
listen guys why am I not just come on it
make it do it do it do it okay don't do
it that whatever all right sorry I don't
know what was going on - maybe I was
reloading at the time I don't know yeah
maybe the next episode could be hunting
down the legendary animals because I
want to know if there's a legendary
beaver there's got to be a legendary
version of every single animal right
that would only make sense let's get
some cocaine in us yeah
wait did that not help my debt I thought
that was gonna help my dead I know Jolly
Jax Junda back oh oh there we go oh hell
yeah there we go golden circle up ready
huh Oh God
well I'm on the wrong way God [ __ ] dick
Oh Bob Frick all right come on guys oh
jeez
oh I goofed it there we go come on there
we go sorry oh god what did we just lose
oh we just lost something real probably
important oh I shouldn't we lost two
wheel we're one wheel down oh oh no oh
[ __ ] I'm sorry
oh he's gonna be so pissed I guess he'll
probably be happy that he has it at all
but I mean he's gonna be so pissed
Danka clunk OH oh my god oh my god oh
geez they did it by the way all of them
did it it will it torn up it weren't me
in deaf okay well
it's not how do we oh no no no no no no
no no why can't you back up up there
wait oh you can back sorry sorry sorry
you can't back up if you hold those stop
buttons are one in perfect shape it
wasn't a trouble now was it no it was a
pleasure let me give you something your
pleasure this provide a man a teacher it
were well for a day teaching to make one
you might be well a while longer make
sure to try and make this thank you
thank you it won't work for anything
chronic but you may not need it too well
see me on my travels and you're in need
of something make sure you come and say
hello hey sorry about destroying it man
do I look like a giant piece of [ __ ]
where do I get some goddamn clothes is
that like at the general store could I
go to the general store and get some
clothes because I am just a goddamn
wreck I'm covered in [ __ ] I've got a
terrible hat everything about me is just
too goddamn devastation I'm gonna go
on this door I'll get some apparel I'm
gonna change up my appearance because I
hello I think that you are being a bit
judgmental what do we say judge not the
ones who judge you and you shall not be
judged so it is alright don't have much
money but I'm hoping that you can give
me something nice and cheap right
ooh that's expensive that is much more
expensive than I can afford no these are
all expensive oh that's this is
expensive these are these are pricey
what I want - I want a possum hat change
of plans everybody all right okay
how do I put this ah all other important
tasks have been reassigned we are gonna
go get a possum hat and where do you
find possums in the woods maybe read
this I guess oh that's nice
I've discovered a recipe valuables
documents here we go maps legendary
animal map let's look at this bad boy
Oh baby also legendary beaver okay
that's good but that's not what I'm
looking for we want the legendary possum
looks like we may not be able to get a
legendary possum man boy boy boy boy big
old floppy boots
I see beavers wait wouldn't possums be
in like a swamp area so if I go back to
the swamp yeah yeah let's go to the
swamp I just
everything has to wait until we get this
hat which way it was a swamp I better
get some this from
oh hello Doctor there you are I guess
it's still looking just to beat up as it
ever was okay anyway we got to go back
into the swamp because I'm gonna get
myself a possum oh I'm gonna give myself
up ow
I gotta get a good possum I gotta figure
it out and I'm gonna track it down
because I know that I got to look up the
right tracks for that who's trying to
talk to me no stop swine stop not here
for you your lucky day so one of them I
do is I'm gonna go on foot for this
because this is about to get intimate
he's about to be good
I got a good feeling about this there
ever there was a place for a possum it
would be in here oh yeah I'm not seeing
much of anything here but I shouldn't
give up hope this early anything can
happen
okay and I'm swimming did I not bring my
bow god damn it huh I'm gonna need my
bow for this because I'm not gonna want
to shoot this I want a good hat hold a
big bullet hole in my possum hat what is
that what is that well that's a gator oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I was just wallowing through that who's
[ __ ] okay
that's not good yeah I got a skip miss
can i skin this whoa that's not good oh
that's a big and can i skin that well
here I go
okay got it hey RC I didn't know I was
going for this come here you come here
you come here you
I'm coming RC just don't code don't get
eaten by a gator goddamn I did not know
that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay here we go this is fine
this is definitely fine it is almost
certainly fine
maybe opossum isn't the right thing in
the swamp maybe I'm just being foolish
about it all right whatever
ha back on let's go into the regular
woods maybe I'm completely off about the
possums here I guess it would inherently
make a little more sense this is
dangerous
well there's real dangerous I got a bad
feeling about this
oh I got a bad feeling about this I got
a bad feeling about this okay we're fine
we're all good we're all good we're all
good howdy hey oh [ __ ] well that was
your fella see maybe you shouldn't have
been stupid well this is how I dismount
okay so should I throw some dynamite at
horse you really need to move ah here we
go to [ __ ]
okay got it
money is this is lit okay no that's not
what I wanted can I please just not have
this be an issue thank you okay man how
many times cuz I almost blow myself up
in a single game awesome
yoo-hoo Damon I want that hat I really
want that wait hang on and I'm on to
something
so I'm over here oh wait I gotta get my
boat get out okay horse you need to give
me my boat all right what have we got
here what have we got here what have we
got here
something's going on here done what is
it
Fox tongue that's not what I'm here
looking for though wait legendary Fox
wait a minute
really I didn't know that I was tracking
the legendary Fox not close not close
this way okay I'm in for this to be the
next episode but I just really want that
possum you know what actually I'm gonna
I'm gonna forego it for now I'm gonna
forego this for now I'm gonna for grow
this for now because it got distracted
what I need to do is I need to finish
out what I started in this episode and
then next episode I'm gonna get that
possum hat I'm gonna get legendary
foxes beavers all that [ __ ] I'm gonna
get them and it'll be fine but for now I
got to do what I gotta do and I gotta go
see John even though I got distracted by
a hat I gotta go see John I gotta get
this taken care of right now
that's my main priority I'll worry about
the rest of it later but for now
God to take care of bidness all right
John I'm a-comin the Grays help has come
in town everybody be happy and rejoice I
am he
here hey you weren't growing these were
you oh you almost got run over Johnny
boy Johnny boy I'm slowing down sure I'm
supposed to be my business partners here
he arranged a meeting I believe bout
some horses a fellow with the scar and a
Mexican yes sir I'll buy the stables
thank you have a wonderful day now have
a wonderful day indeed I will be out of
your hair promptly and I'll go see my
lovely scarf Brendon those two spillin
love have you strung them up because
they didn't marry their cousins yet
hello
Xavier and have you met my partner
Arthur Morgan no I met you son the
sheriff
okay mr. gray here was saying how he had
problems with a family a family of
degenerates
oh well nobody likes the generous
Wagoner inbred sons they ruined this
county
they killed my uncle you know that ain't
right problem is we can't be seen to get
too close and we've got gold Yankee
we've got gold ain't no Yankee friend
ain't nothing my daddy came over on a
boat from Scotland honest I teach in the
braithwaite's
goddamn peasants I don't very good
mangroves slave [ __ ] look at him
enough these are prize torches I'm
talking about them they'll get you five
thousand five thousand for horses easy
where do we sell them these $5,000
horses over in Clements Cove so over
there we'll run them out of state and
give you a fifty cents on the dollar
mister you got yourself a deal
just keep us away from this okay we I
mean my sense is we keep all horse
wrestling away from the public goddamn
I'm looking more and more just like a
complete hillbilly game I'm an absolute
train wreck of a human oh hey guys we've
been robbed folk all these years yeah he
doesn't know
but we can't even a third of that fair
enough
make sense to me this place is well
guarded already no point blasting in
their wake a fake where they're looking
to purchase three armed men you'd be
armed if you were about to spend $5,000
we should go in the back way though boy
too many questions
well I don't know if I got the look of a
guy that has $5,000 because I definitely
don't have $5,000 I've never had one
worth $1,000 gave it a fart
I lost it immediately
gentleman yeah we're here to see about
some horses horses yeah we had an
appointment with mr. Braithwaite I
believe yeah I never heard about any of
this
her partner wanted to make a significant
investment in some stables down here but
perhaps we should look elsewhere
well alright good don't okay then
someone gonna find you thank you
you guys move on you yeah don't mind me
oh I forgot I was in cinematically oh
wait on me okay
cuz I got a gator on the back of my
horse and just cuz my hat's a little
swampy and just cuz my beards got flex a
big [ __ ] that I blew up with some
dynamite don't mean that I ain't no sort
of class and man where are you going I
don't know what I'm doing jump I'm just
pressing the button okay hello I got a
funkalicious feeling that the tracking
system from the hold down the button
ain't do so good look I don't know what
I'm doing
look I'm lucky I have you guys around
you guys are so good to be happens if I
going to everything like blasted drunk
there we go wait wait there we go give
me a bourbon that's what I'm talking
about
I'm only cool I'm literally the coolest
guy there ever was okay you got it buddy
hey pal friend oh we're here to buy
horse
I have al Gator skin you want you've
good price one horse one skin fair deal
you like I like we handshake come on
bring it here give me horse
what horse in hand hello heard you got
some horse
mmm we always got horses dude horses on
me I don't get you friends yeah you do
come on
listen why don't you get out of here you
Scarface and your greaser buddy whoa
don't like officials
we ain't officials we're connoisseurs
look gonna do some Breeden's come on now
partner okay fine follow me
oh you drop the flag studs available for
purchase or for working that's what
you're interested in what is your boys
interested in
we represent a famous stable and stud
farm from Saratoga that sell
unofficially of course
this year's cerberus hey good boy
Cerberus real reliable stud okay all
right
I'm sure they they're fine with that
okay no need to tell me otherwise I got
it easy easy easy now you're gonna tear
them up to a horse okay oh yeah you're
gonna lead the stage okay come on come
on you're good you're good you're good
it's all good this way come on Bob we're
gonna give you a pat every time I see
the option for a pat I'm padding
I just love the horses so much come on
now come on Marsten you rockport I'll
cover up the back if there's any
problems we regroup at Clemmons coast
okay horsey
what are you doing that's Carly what are
you doing Oh what the hell I'm not sure
you would want to shoot that risk of
hitting the horses but whatever
yep that was a horse hit damn it shot
slam hole okay where
hey good this guy's is being an [ __ ]
okay good thing that horse goes the way
that needs to cuz I certainly am NOT
we might be clear but I highly doubt it
and how many times are we gonna do these
to these people and be like hey wait
ever since those [ __ ] moved in from
out of town suddenly we're getting
murdered by the score and everybody's
dying and all our horses are getting
stolen like man this is a slice of
something terrible
I got a few bullet holes is probably
okay I ain't too worried about it
they're pretty tough horses hey come on
now I know you're happy oh boy okay I'm
good no that's done that is dynamite
that's dynamite
do not lasso a horse with dynamite hey
you come on this way hello come on you
don't give in let's get this over with
okey-dokey where's glooms go this
Plemons go but doesn't look like they're
paying 5,000 for horses
hello are you going to rob us this is
today the day you die
hello I am a good businessman I'm
competent full of business opportunities
look at my hat and judge me heard you
was heard you paid good prices for
horses Oh we'll buy more or less
anything pop that's so sure pop I'm clay
Davies that's my brother Clive we're
twins John Arthur Xavier so what are you
Cuban no I don't like Cubans that's so
maybe why what do you care
you ain't Cuban maybe I like Cubans oh
you're funny
he's funny tiny funny Clive Clive don't
talk we're twins but I was born first he
came out all yelling black but he's okay
hmm sure yeah I know these horses they
ain't yours but I like you and I'll give
you I'd give you 654 I was told we could
get up to $5,000 for man I was told the
moon was made of ladies tears only it
ain't true
not one little bit but I like you boys
but I ain't got more than 700 OB you
won't it or you want to ride them fellas
into town and maybe someone there I'll
hang you we're gonna need more than that
ain't got no more money pop here take it
or leave it
ain't no one round here got $5,000 boys
but nice meetin ya see you boys again
I hope come on man it's very obvious now
that would have been worth more so we
got ripped off just because he didn't
have the money on him but oh well I
guess we got no choice it's like when
you're dealing with storekeepers in
video game
imagine we he was gonna be wonderfully
rich at the end of it we feel like prize
idiots still made some money I mean it
didn't go well but made some money you
can sell horses to clay and Clive at
Clemens home they will pay more than a
stable for stolen horses but less for
purchases that make sense what about
wild horses oh that's gonna be any good
but that's an option
oh boy boss that is a lot happening that
boss that is just a lot so just gonna
quietly put some money in the thing
alright I know there's something else
that I was gonna build but I don't
remember I just like offloading that
[ __ ] alright Dutch boss Dutch my god we
cannot survive with this racket here
sweatin is such but maybe a little
gentle perspiration until we know more
ain't too much harm and waste and good
liquor on sweat
I think you should pay mr. Trelawney a
visit and find out exactly what he knows
and who he spoke to take Charles Wynn on
the side of the pair of you make us send
out its secrets okay okay nothing
Charles is pretty imposing my beard is
getting quiet rustling hey Charles you
want to go intimidate somebody Josh I
need you for some business in town come
on okay come on Charles
Cobb along now been a long time since we
went first went hunting Charles wait
which one's thrilling is Trelawny the
guy we busted out of that jail cell the
carton
someone please make a compilation of all
the times I'm okay oh damn it what the
hell that's not even a tree how is that
a tree that I can actually hit working
for another interesting I'm in plain
sight
yeah so spirits seem good in the new
camp I mean we got some space between us
and their mess now ain't seen no more
Pinkertons for a while there's these
bounty hunters of course but that's
don't seem too worried about it
nope can't believe they're still coming
after us we didn't even get away with
the money yeah but they don't know that
of course Trelawney I've only met him a
couple of times but he's he's a strange
one
yep thanks for the input on that one
he's just a cockroach in fancy britches
that's not what he gets in the nooks and
crannies the rest of us can we just need
to find him before so is the same guy so
why do we need to intimidate him I
thought he owed us we busted him out I
mean it is just up here you dummy
I thought we he would oh uh scuzz we
busted him out didn't we
why do you reckon that you don't need to
know why hello mr. trelawney someone got
here first
okay well there's a whole lot of nothing
happening over here can I look at this
there we go no this food very touched
looks like you left uh what do we got
here
certify that Blanc is a holder of blank
shares inclusive in the above company
subject to the provisions of the
memorandum and articles association
their oven that the sum of $1 has been
paid on each of the said shares solitary
Blanc okay Tacitus Kilgore mining
company wait Tacitus Kilgore that's the
guy that's the name that they use right
hmm everybody makes their bed pretty
recently I'd say I guess maybe 12 hours
ago but no body not yet
right okay all right sure whatever you
say man if you can find it okay oh you
know good all right you know I was gonna
get those yeah how do I get out away I
track this guy a lot better expect to
see Trelawney standing know normally
scams himself into the best hotel in
town you know when me and Xavier went
down with Trelawney to get Sean after
the bar fight I swear he talked the
whole way and never actually said it
damn thing I thought you knew that's his
special tab they could beat one in my
house away by now we can track them that
far if we need to depends on how much
you want to find yeah I still ain't sure
where did I lose it
oh they went that way oh jeez I've
missed that oh I guess we don't need to
go that far because here they are hello
hi hello sir why are we approaching you
with such weird caution yeah we're
looking for our friend I don't think
he's here you've seen a strange sort of
feller sort of formal strange sure
formal uses a cane looks a lot like this
one
oh well that was a sucker punch buddy
get whomped you can't get whomped cuz
I've got a whomping for you get your
whomping x' now whomp I'm real good at
whomping deliveries all right well he
looks pretty done I'm just gonna get
this guy here thank you
hello $28.00 holy [ __ ] hey buddy how you
doing man how you doing to have a moment
with your testicles real quick here yeah
sure okay yeah I believe that all right
break it feels which cornfield left
manner
okay Braithwaite one more for good
measure okay goodbye looky there my
friend
okay yeah a little bit I'm in a good
mood I'm a generous man real generous
that's a Braithwaite manor okay whatever
you say man after you there okay thank
you
let's go expect a cinematic time oh yeah
so uh this whole Braithwaite grey thing
do you think that um you're this it
worth bothering in this area maybe cuz
without any people we've killed because
just kill them all take the money
a hundred things just depends if any of
them involve us you think he'll talk
course you talk he'd sell his own sister
to save a train fare
does he have sister know how not to talk
though least I don't think he does I
don't know why that still deals with him
oh it's disappearing for weeks on end
he's got his uses man well loyalty
matters to Dutch of course but it's
Trelawny loyal can of I guess you're
lonely ain't exactly diss more just got
a big mouth
don't worry if he talks
I'll goddamn find out what he said okay
whatever you say man I believe you why
wouldn't I believe you ain't nothing not
to believe you about man back to the
Civil War place why are they over here
why would they keep him over here in a
cornfield it's amazing out actually like
I do recognize when games were like go
back to the same place over and over
again but this one doesn't make it seem
like that you are going back to the same
set pieces in like the first game
everything is crammed together closer
than it seems it has this ability to
make everything seem like it's
incredibly far away like the distances
are just huge and I love that about the
game but also at the same time it's like
okay I'm sorry to say that we're all
just in the same area here just circling
around because I mean the area that
we're in this entire area of this game
no bigger than like a small town and
then they're like you know that count
over there the five buildings that's it
it's the one the cornfield what about
the cornfield that's not corn that's
wheat you can't fool the endlessness
baby corn that corn nice tabacky you
can't fool me
no that's tabacky what is that wacky
tabacky who's this
this is a corn none of this looks like
corn to me Oh corn I see I see I see
hello hey how's it going mr. otra Lonnie
gun maybe not best idea
go get the mock I could handle this
okey-dokey then
so what you're saying is I have to go
hunt these people down
well that's one down all right I heard
that oh I heard that oh ho ho who's here
hello
I'm gonna pull out the special oh I
don't have the shotgun for this one I'm
gonna just do a double whammy of good
fun here I know there's one in here
won't there you are
oh you're running you're running you're
running you're running and sorry come on
what are you doing all right where's uh
where's the birds all right where's the
birds then huh where birds I don't see
no birds you've talked about birds
wait he's dumped his gear look around he
can't have gone far
wait he's naked please tell me he's
naked please tell me he's naked please
absolutely tell me he's bought ass naked
oh well that's not gonna go for you
buddy well shouldn't have done that
yeah that's what friends do for each
other right yeah thank you 27 bucks hell
yeah you okay yeah
wait who what the [ __ ] one for you and
one for you and the ankle and the
shoulder and that's good dad damn it
three for that guy and didn't even die
oh come on
how tough are you how many Poles and
bowls and nails the Evod I [ __ ] up the
joint how many nails do you eat you eat
nails a nail eat you like nails
I got nails if you want nails I got
nails need nails I bet you eat a lot of
nails huh Bank how is that guy not dead
how in the hell is that guy not dead
maybe scripted not to be dead bit holy
[ __ ] that guy stood where where there is
bang okay [ __ ] criminy are you
kidding are you kidding me okay there he
goes
good god of course it was gonna take
forever to kill that guy alright but I
gotta go find this guy up top because
these guys have yeah it sure don't know
wait what oh this house nothing nothing
at all thank God they got so much money
hell yeah I'm up to 300 bucks already
hell yeah I mean you know I had a lot
more money before
whatever I suppose I'll be okay all
right you sack of [ __ ] we've helped you
enough now you help us okay attach the
coal star the mine what you tell not
much come down seems you stirred up
quite a hornet's nest in blackboard you
take your lonely back to camp I'll catch
up with you okay yeah yeah all right and
with that that will bring this episode
of red that would never mind never mind
seems to be more what's left of it even
that ain't the way I remember it yeah
through that anyway that will end it for
this oh my god my beard we could have
huge that will end it for this episode
of Red Dead Redemption - thank you
everybody so much for watching hope
you're enjoying it so far I know I am in
the next episode we'll be farming up and
hunting down some legendary beaver so
look forward to that thank you again and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye